- If you're watching this,
then you know by now a huge
problem is heading our way.
An emergency meeting
is being called.
Our usual place immediately.
Free bagels.
(dramatic music)
I've made a shocking discovery.
(typing)
(phone rings)
I need you to get me in
touch with NASA immediately.
- Well, NASA and I aren't really
on speaking terms these days.
- Well, that'll change.
When you tell them that
the moon is out of orbit.
(dramatic music)
- There's no need to panic.
- I'm not crazy!
(dramatic music)
(explosions)
- Why are they lying
about all this?
- [Holdenfield] It's
too late to stop.
(dramatic flare)
- You knew all this was
happening before NASA.
- You're the
unidentified source?
- Oh, yes.
(extravagant music)
- We're dealing with
an intelligent entity.
We're planning a mission
to attack this thing.
I'm asking you for your help.
- Say yes, Brian.
(blaring guitar)
- I need you to be brave.
- If the moon really is what
you think it is, suit up.
♪ I see the bad moon arising ♪
- [Man in space station] You
have got a big gravity wave
coming your way.
You have to launch now!
- Did he say gravity wave?
(beep)
♪ I see trouble on the way ♪
- We're under water, guys!
Uh... That's crazy.
(blaring instrumental)
♪ I hear hurricanes
are blowing ♪
- Whoa! Slow down!
Whoo!
- [Jocinda] What's the plan?
- [Brian] Save the
moon, save earth.
- Brian, what are you doing!?
- It's flying itself!
Wait for it.
(guns clicking into place)
Let's go, you son of a...
(lasers)
♪ Don't go around tonight ♪
- Yes!
♪ Well it's bound
to take your life ♪
- Hang on!
- Everybody, hang on!
- We're going to get you home.
♪ There's a bad
moon on the rise ♪
(camera click)
(sirens)
- It's on airplane mode.
♪ Looks like we're in
for nasty weather ♪